[Music]
were there moments when you broke down
when you were in tears honestly
i'm really proud of myself because i
like kept myself together
literally i was like i barely cried
corinne olympio speaks out about life
after the bachelor in paradise scandal
that rocked her world she told et
thursday she's been in therapy to deal
with the fallout it was just like sad
it's like kind of you feel a little
helpless because
it's like it's in your own brain so it's
like you're trying to explain
it to people and they just
you know they aren't getting it to the
extent that like you know it is
so it's like
you know it's like i'm trying to like
explain this blackout and it's like oh
my god i think it was just a combination
of the three different alcohols in such
a short period of time in that heat you
know with my like anxiety i took my
medication i had a different
time that day right before i got there
so it was like all like boom like right
then
and so yeah and yeah
scary there have now been these new
rules instituted in paradise and on
future bachelor shows a certain number
of drinks per hour people have to go
tell a producer before they want to hook
up with someone
what do you think do you think those
rules are necessary well because there
is a lot of drinking involved i'm like
okay i mean it's a little overkill but
like it's safe so
can't beat safe this third party who
filed this complaint i think that
producer was a friend of yours
when was last time you spoke to that
person
we're still really good friends i'm
friends with everybody's after the fact
i i guess i was expressing that i didn't
even remember talking to damario
and that's when they were like oh okay
like this is
we gotta do something about this you
said that producer
um yes it was i was told again i don't
remember anything from that day so i was
told that i didn't even realize that i
had spoken to him earlier in the day i
wasn't planning on doing paradise and
you know what something just drew me to
it
i went and i feel like
i don't know i just feel like
i don't i don't know how to word it
maybe put to a test i don't know i just
i feel like for my own self and you know
i feel like it was a really good
stepping stone in growth for me
and i'm i'm really happy with myself now
you gonna make america korean again i
already did
[Music]